well Hank the votes have been tabulated
and by a count of four thousand three
hundred thirty six to eleven the
nerdfighters have decided we should make
more videos more often as Hank green
would say cue the intro well hello there
puff haven't seen you in a while
Hank today's video comes in two parts
part one question Tuesday Hank this
video isn't going to contain a lot of
jokes so to make up for it I'm going to
do a question Tuesday next Monday and it
is going to be joke tacular so
nerdfighters if you could leave me a lot
of questions and comments specifically
if you could ask me questions about a
book or books so that I can have kind of
a themed question Tuesday on Monday that
would be super helpful part two
worldsuck I'm a big believer in giving
money to charitable organizations like
Save the Children and Oxfam because they
do amazing work and they do it with
really impressive efficiency but I have
a bit of a problem with the way they
raise money I mean we all know the basic
strategy you take a picture preferably
of children preferably of them not
smiling and then you make it black and
white so it looks more depressing then
you put some sad music in the background
Hank to put it in terms that a wall cat
could understand the basic theme of your
average global poverty charity
advertisement is this
now here's the thing guilt works these
places need to raise money and guilt is
probably the best way to raise money but
the weird thing that those
advertisements end up doing is making
you think that the poor are in some way
fundamentally different from us that
they're like of them and so in our minds
it becomes this formulation we should
help them but it's not at them problem
it's an us problem we need to help us
the whole reason I've been thinking
about this is because of a nerdfighter
named Sean Sean was in graduate school
at Notre Dame when one day he decided
that he needed to do something about
world suck and so he moved to Bangladesh
his project is called on culture and he
makes all these videos showing what
poverty is really like in Bangladesh and
he's also been using money he was saving
for an Xbox 360 to help kids go to
school and to buy pencils and to do all
kinds of amazing things because like
Xbox 360 money goes a long way in
Bangladesh I mean it costs less than
five bucks for a kid to go to school for
six months and yet every single day kids
have to drop out because they don't have
enough money what strikes me is so
amazing about Sean is that he realized
that poverty isn't about them it's about
us and he just went I'm gonna be honest
with you Hank I couldn't do that I mean
I worry about the quality of the
drinking water in Kentucky it's nothing
personal Kentuckians you know I love you
this is what the nerdfighters have
taught me in the last 15 months there is
no them there are only facets of us in
fact every time I've tried to imagine
them in the last 15 months there's been
a nerdfighter who proved to me that that
them was part of us and that's no
different for the kid Sean's working
with in Bangladesh they may not know in
your pants jokes they may not speak
English they may not have high-speed
Internet connections but they're still
part of us so here's what I'm proposing
Hanks John's xbox360 money is only going
to go so far so we're gonna help him
help people in Bangladesh this isn't
charity it's a kind of experiment in
communities so definitely give money to
Save the Children and Oxfam like giving
money to this project does not get you
off the hook from real charity so first
we're gonna help Sean link in the
sidebar I just gave myself a mustache
and then we're going to be able to see
exactly where our money goes exactly who
it helps and exactly how it helps them
because Sean's going to make videos at
his YouTube channel god I love the
Internet Hank on YouTube I've made this
video response to one of Sean's videos
so you can see the kind of work that
he's doing and I really
hope that you and the nerdfighters will
join me in helping to supplement his
xbox360 fund we're gonna get to see
where every dollar goes I think it's a
fascinating experiment and best of all
like everything I like in this world
it's all about us nerdfighters dftba and
yes that is real Hank I'll see you
tomorrow